[音楽]
4ダーカーバー
実に醜い鳥です
顔は心所ミソをつけたよー
まだられ
くちばしは平たくて耳まで裂けています
足はまるでヨボヨボで1件とも歩けません
他の鳥わー
よだかの顔を見ただけでも嫌になってしまうという具合でしていた
例えばひばりも
あまり美しい鳥ではありませんが
小高よりはずっと上だと思っていましたので夕方などよ馬鹿2アウト
サモサも嫌そうに湿りと目を瞑りながら
首襲っポエムてるのでした
小さなおしゃべりの鳥などはいつでもよだかの真っ向から悪口をしましたし
また出てきたねまああのザマ踊ら本当にポリの仲間の面汚しだよ
エマーノ口の大きい歩とさ
きっとカエルの親類かなんかなんだよ
長袖です
色高げないただの誰かならばこんな生半可の小さい鳥はもう名前を聞いただけでも
ブルブル震えて顔色を変えて体を縮めて木の葉の限りでも隠れたでしょ
ところがよだかは本当は誰かの兄弟でも人類でもありませんでした
帰ってよだかはあの美しいカワセミやポリの中の宝石のような
8すずめのにいさんでした
8スズメは花の蜜を食べカワセミはお魚を食べ
よだかはハム子を取って食べるのでした
夜中には鋭い爪も鋭いくちばしもありませんでしたから
んなに弱い取りでもよ高を怖がるはずはなかったのです
それならパッカという名の過ぎたことは不思議なようです
これは一つはの高の数
羽が売り上げに強く風を切って勝てるときなどはまるで誰かのように見えた区
もう一つは鳴き声がすると来てやはりどこか誰かに似ていたためです
私論墓はこれを非常に気にかけてり上がっていました
それですからよだかの顔さえ見ると肩をいからせ
早く名前を改めの名前を改めろという
応答誰かが夜中の家へ行ってまいりました
おいいるかわいい
ガーお前は名前を変えないのか
ずいぶんも前も恥知らずだなぁ
お前と俺ではよっぽど人格が違うんだよ
例えば俺はあ
青い空を床まででも飛んでいく
お前は
曇って薄暗い日か
夜でなくちゃ出てこない
それから
俺の口箸やすめを見ろ
そしてよく前のと比べてみるがいい
あんまり無理です
私の名前は私が勝手につけたんではありません
神様からクラスたんです
いいよ
俺のななら神様からもらったんだと言ってもよかろう
お前のはいわば
俺とよると
両方から借りてあるんださあ
返せ
レバー無理です
bully じゃない
俺がいいな教えてやろう
映像っていう
1贈答ないいなだろう
そこで名前を変えるには解明の披露てのをしないといけない
いいかそれらのスピへ七蔵と書いた知らずな感じです
私は以来一蔵と申しますと
往生を言ってみんなの所お辞儀して回るんだ
んなことを
とてもできません
いやできるそうしろ
もし
あさっての朝までよ前がそうしなかったん
すぐ掴み殺すぞ
掴み殺してしまうからそう思え
レバー
朝ての朝早く鳥のうちおい
件ずつ回ってお前が来たどうか聞いて歩く
犬でも来なかったって家があったらなぁ
貴様もその時がおしまいだぞ
てっ
それが母あんまり無理じゃありませんか
なことズレぐらいならー
しファンを
んだほうがましです
今すぐ
殺してください
よーく後で考えてごらっ
一蔵なんてそんなに悪いだじゃないよ
ん
誰かは大きな羽をいっぱいに広げて自分の素の方へ飛んで帰っていきました
野田可愛い
と目を瞑って考えました
い僕は
なぜこうみんなにやがられるんだろう
僕の顔はミソをつけたようで
口は避けてるからなぁ
それだって僕は今まで何にも悪いことをしたことがない
赤ん坊のメジロがつから落ちていた時は助けて州へ連れてってやっ
そしたらメジロは
赤ん坊まるでむすっとからでも取り返すように僕から引き離したんだな
ひどく僕を笑ったっけ
今度は市造田なんて
首絵札をかけるなんて
話だなぁ
辺りはもう薄暗くなっていました
依田交わすから飛び出しました
雲が意地悪く光って低く垂れています
よだかばまるで雲とすれすれになってをとなく空を飛び回りました
それからにわかに色が彼は口を大きく開いて
羽をまっすぐに貼ってまるで家のように空を横切りました
小さな羽虫が行くしても行く意識もとの濃度に入りました
ん
体が次につくかつかないうちによだかは左とまた揃え跳ね上がりました
雲はねずみ色になり
向こうの山には山や家の日が真花です
よだかな思い切って跳ぶ時は空がまるで二つに切れたように思われます
一匹のカブトムシがよだかの喉に入ってひどくもがきます
よだかはすぐそれを飲み込みましたが
このときなんだか背中がちょっとしたように思いました
もはもうま
東の方だけ山や家の日が赤く写って恐ろしいようです
よだかば胸がつかえたように思いながらまた側へ登りました
父
一つまた一匹のカブトムシが夜中のなどに入りました
そしてまるでよだかの道筆界でバタバタしました
よだかはそれを無理に飲み込んでしまいましたが
の時
急に胸楽器きっとして
のだから大胡声を上げて泣き出しました
泣きながらぐるぐるぐるぐる空を巡ったのです
ああああああ
カブトムシ等沢山の羽生シガー
毎晩とクリックをされる
そしてとバカだ一つの国が
今度は誰かに殺される
それがこんなに辛いんだ
our を連ねる
さらにズルい
僕はもう
虫を食べないで上徹しの
いやぁぁ
その前にも誰かが僕を殺すだろ
その前に
僕は遠くの遠くの空の向こうリィってしまおう
山家家の日はだんだん水のように流れて広成
ふもも破格燃えているようです
よだかはまっすぐに弟の翡翠のところへ飛んでいきました
綺麗なカワセミもちょうど起きて遠くの山火事を見ていたところでした
そしてよだか登りてきたのを見てみました
にいさんこんばんは何か宮の御用ですか
僕は今度遠いところへいいからね
その前ちょっとお前に会いに来たよ
23言っちゃいけませんよ8スズメマンダ遠くにいるんですし僕一人ぼっちになって
しまうじゃありませんか
も仕方ないのだ
今日は何も言わないでくれ
お前もね
どうしても虎掛ければならない時のほかわー
いたずらにお魚を捕ったりしないようにしてくれ
ねっ
イーサン通したんですまあもうちょっと待ちなさい
唾でいても同じだ
すずめ
あとでよろしく言ってやってくれ
さようなら
もう
合わないよ
たようなもん
よだかは泣きながら自分の家へ帰ってまいり
短い夏のよう
を開けかかっていました
シダの葉は家の霧ボスって
青く冷たく揺れました
よだかは高く騎士キシキシと泣きました
そうして巣の中をきちんと片付けきれい
体中の羽開けをそろえ
いつから取り出しました
霧が晴れてお日様がちょうど仕出しから登りました
よだかは裏 gura するほど眩しいのをこらえて
やの読みそっちへ飛んでいきました
おひさー
どうぞ私をあなたのところエッツでてってくださー
焼けて死んでも構いません
[音楽]
私のような醜い体でも焼ける時には小さな光を出すでしょ
どうか私を連れてってくださ
ても言ってもお日様は近くなりませんでした
帰ってだんだん小さく多くなりながらお日様が言いました
会えるぞ
4高だなぁ
なるほど釣り分フラッパーど
コインや空を飛ん運営
星理想頼んでごらん
まえうおお
昼の鳥ではないのだからなぁ
しっ
よだか落ち着を一つしたと思いましたなぁ
急に暗くだしてとうとう野原の草の上に落ちてしまいました
してまるで夢を見ているようでした
体が2
と赤や黄色星の間を上っていったり
ところでも糧に側されたり
誰かが来て体をさんだりしたようです
[音楽]
寝台ものが
にわかに顔に落ちました
よだかは目を開きました
本の若いススキの葉から
梅雨が滴ったのでした
大すっかり夜になって
空わぁを黒く一面の星が瞬いていました
よだかはこのへ飛び上がります
恋やの山やけど日は馬鹿です
よだかはその日のかすかな照りと冷たい星明かりの中を飛び巡りました
それから多い店舗日巡りました
ました
そして思い切って西の空ぼ
あの美しいオリオンの星の方へまっすぐに跳びながら叫びました
ほっさー
西の青白いよ星さ
どうか私をあなたの所へ連れてってくださいー
痩せて死んでも構いませ
[音楽]
オリオンは勇ましい歌を続けながら
よだかなで終わってんで相手にしませんでした
よだかは泣きそうになって路沿いを奏してそれからジャスト踏み止まって大一変
とび巡りました
しっ
それから南の多いリザの方へまっすぐに跳びながら叫びます
星さーん
南の青いお星さーん
[音楽]
どうか私をあなたの所へ連れてってくださ
だけて死んでも構いません
[音楽]
大犬は青や紫焼き屋美しく忙しくまた抱きながら言います
馬鹿を言うな
お前なんかいっぱいどんな問題かは母がとり者はないか
前の羽でここまで来るには億年超年
邑久町年東
そしてまた別の方を向きました
夜中はがっかりして沿いをしてそれからまたに変
とび巡りました
しっ
吉
4それからまた思い切ってきたの大熊星の方へまっすぐに跳びながら叫びました
北の葵お星さま
あなたの所へどうか私を連れてってくださ
大熊星は静かに聴いました
余計なことを考えるものではない
少し頭を冷やしてきなさい
を言う時は氷山の浮いている海の中に飛び込むか
近くに海がなかったら
氷を浮かべたコップの水の中に飛び込むのは一方ダーガー
よだかはがっかりしていろいろ落ちてそれからも4変
空を巡りました
ています
[音楽]
そしてもう一度東から今登った天の川向こう岸のは死の星に叫びました
東白いよ星さま
ああああああ
どうか私をあなたの所へ連れてってくださいん
焼けて死んでも構いません
しっ
橋は王府にしました
いやーとてもとても話にも何にもだらん
星になるにはそれ相応の身分でなくちゃいかん
またほど金もいるのだ
4仲間もうすっかり力を落としてしまう
羽を閉じて地に落ちていきました
そしてもう一尺で地面にその弱ヤシがつくというとき
よだかはにわかに戻しの曜日こらえ跳ね上がります
空の中ほど生きてよ高はまるでは詞楽府まを襲う時するようにずっと体を揺すって毛を
逆立てました
5つ
シェイ
と高く高くさてりました
その声はまるでた壁下野原や林眠っていた他の鳥ばみんな目を覚ましてブルブル震え
ながら
井深馳走に星空を見上げました
よだかはどこまでもどこまでも真っ直ぐり空へ登っていきました
もう山やての一羽たばこの吸い殻のて害にしか見えません
の馬場登って登っていきました
寒さに息は胸にしの不幸りましたプー気が薄くなったために羽もそれはそれは忙しく
動かさなければなりませんでしたそれなのに
星の大きさはさっきと少しも変わりません
スプーン行きは
色のようです様さんシボがまるで犬のように夜中を刺しました
よだかは羽がすっかりしびれてしまいましたそしてナビ多分ダメを上げてもう一ん
空を見ました
これがよだかの最後でした
もうよだかは落ちているのか登っているのか
逆さになっているのか上を向いているのかもわかりませんでした
心持ちは安が彼にその血の付いた大きなくちばしば
横に曲がってはいましたな
少し
笑っておりました
えっああああああ
しばらくっ
よだかははっきり
まだこう開きました
をして
自分の身体が暇
銀の子のような青い美しい光になって
静かに燃えているのを見ました
すぐ隣はカシオピアザでしっ
あ窓側の青白い光は
すぐ後ろになっていました
をしてい
依田可能欲しいは燃え続けばし
いつまでもいつまでも
燃え続けばした
今でもまだ
萌えて言います
はぁ
母なの
に注意
を闇に
んじゃまた
[音楽]
新しい
欲しいよー
オレはー
タール
ですか
あれ
そう
平和ん
アーサー
は誰かしらあなたなの
頭わー
[音楽]
e 4
4 author と g 農地や
いい
4位
鬼神
いいいいいい
られる新しい
欲しいよー
きっ
air
ああ知恵ですかーっ
s しっ
ています
あーああシイラあなただ
の歌詞
私
[音楽]
彼があああああ
padi の橋
4を
me too
earth
あーなああああかシイラ
あなたなあのお菓子だああ
ます